y'all did good everybody did good we did
so good and that was only our second
time ever doing it all the way through
least favorite
this is ruthless
dallas she's pitchy sometimes but she's
so far advanced than every other person
her age but next to the other girls
you're like
hold on we gave dallas this song to
really test her vocal range and her
singing is so incredible
but i need dallas to deliver right now i
need her to hit her high notes and i
need her to
be a performer and give us everything
she's got okay who's your second
my second biggest name
because leah is older and should be like
better than everyone because she's not
then i would keep doubts
because with time she's gonna be
out of control
i'm definitely bringing everything megan
said to the audition with me but now i
need the girls to take this run through
and make it even bigger even better
because i will be deciding who
is in the group so
their future in exomg pop literally
depends on tomorrow
[Music]
you